[Musique]
bonsoir patrick fox vous êtes médecin
généraliste à toulouse bonsoir à vous
pascal dureau médecin généraliste à
vénissieux délégué national du syndicat
mg france 4 phases 4 dates clés le 3 mai
le 19 mai le 9 juin et le 30 juin
est ce que c'est un calendrier
suffisamment clair patrick forte
oui il faut je crois que c'est les gens
attendaient des mesures de ce type là
ils veulent une sortie de crise mais je
crois que cette sortie de crise doivent
s'accompagner d'une accélération de la
vaccination qui actuellement semble au
moins du point de vu de médecin
jaillissent que je suis dans nos
cabinets être mise à mal par le rocher
de beaucoup de patients de vaccins du
vaccin astrazeneca
c'est le seul dont nous sommes
actuellement dotées on attend le vaccin
johnson dans les jours qui viennent mais
aussi sera tellement petites doses que
c'est pas ça qui va accélérer la
vaccination je crois qu'il faut on
d'accélérer la création notamment chez
les personnes jeunes les travailleurs
chez les enseignantes les gens qui
tiennent un commerce
les gens qui veulent travailler demain
il faut les protéger il faut leur ouvrir
une perspective viable pour les mois qui
viennent pascal dureau oui je partage
tout à fait l'acquisition de mon
confrère
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous nous sommes
favorables et vaccination énergie le
plus tôt possible
je veux dire que si aujourd'hui les plus
de 55 ans rechigne à se faire vacciner
les moins de 55 ans sont très désireux
de le faire
moi je suis pour vacciner les gens
volontaires et moi aujourd'hui déjà si
les personnes à risque même à faire à 55
ans les vaccine parce que je rappelle
que c'est une sont codées
recommandations et que la mm est à
partir de 18 emplois ring il ya beaucoup
d'éléments dans ce calendrier de
déconfinement progressif pour résumer le
3 mai il y aura la fin de la règle des
10 km enfin des attestations le 19 mai
les terrasses qui sont à limiter à six
personnes vont rouvrir les commerçants
essentiel aussi les yeux de coûts dit
culture avec des jauges tout cela en
tout cas ça reste conditionnée quand
même à un taux d'incidence inférieur à
400 cas pour 100000 habitants les
restaurants aussi et les cafés on le
voit ici un vrai ouvrir le 9 juin
vous parliez de la vaccination justement
est ce que ces mesures elles sont
conformes à la course contre la montre
que nous menons actuellement que nous
nous tentons de mener en tout cas
difficilement avec la vaccination à
patrick faute oui ça ne me semble pas
opposée à la vaccination gagnent au
contraire je crois que il faut qu'on
valorise la vaccination en disant aux
gens regardez ce que la veulent la
vaccination autorise de retourner vers
une vie à peu près normale
nous allons avoir comme l'été dernier on
sait que ce virus à des ondulations à
peu près tous les six mois une vague la
prochaine vague s'il y en a une ça sera
pour l'automne
on va avoir trois quatre mois de paie ou
de répit profitons-en pour revivre un
peu pour sortir s'oxygéner se vacciner
et et profitez de la vie je crois que
c'est tellement dur actuellement on voit
dans nos cabinets des gens qui souffrent
des gens qui sont au bout du rouleau
des gens qu'ils en ont marre de ne pas
sortir des devant leurs écrans télé
travail avec la famille toute la journée
je crois qu'il faut qu'on donne des
perspectives aux gens cette perspective
c'est une vie normale une vaccination
faciliter une facilité et sécurisé
pascal dureau votre avis là-dessus
imaginons que cette campagne de
vaccination elle n'avance pas je veux
dire comme prévu vu les indicateurs qui
reste quand même de l'épidémie qui reste
quand même très haut
est ce que finalement ce calendrier il
n'est pas un peu explosif
toute façon je crois qu'on pourra pas
tenir plus longtemps les gens ils ont
peuvent plus ils sont au bord de la
crise de nerfs à la part du temps on a
des des phénomènes de dépression on a
des gens qui sont agressifs et je crois
qu'il est vraiment temps de lâcher un
peu du lest mais il faut appeler chacun
la responsabilité la responsabilité
c'est de vacciner la responsabilité
c'est de porter un masque
lorsqu'on est proche la responsabilité
c'est que quand on est malade on reste
chez soi voilà que chacun soit bien
responsable on est responsable et
solidaire et je me vaccine parce que je
suis solidaire la vaccination les bacs
en actes individuels spéciaux tels actes
collectifs et qui fait qui montre qu'on
a envie de vivre en société
alors vous avez entendu tout à l'heure à
ces français est bon c'est assez mitigé
quand même en tout est une question qui
se pose est ce qu'il faut élargir la
vaccination à la population on sait
d'ores et déjà que le 1er mai les plus
de 18 ans les personnes obèses pourront
se faire vacciner
patrick vote oui c'est déjà une bonne
ouverture mais je crois qu'il faudrait
que c'est encore plus pragmatique aux
etats unis ils ont décidé que toutes
adultes de plus de 18 ans seraient
pourraient être vaccinées s'il en fait
la demande je crois qu'il faut qu'on
procède de la même façon il faut que
toute personne de plus de 18 ans
puissent avoir un vaccin on a un panel
de vaccins il faut qu'on les constats
d'appât aux effets secondaires
potentiels d un épisode et il faut qu'on
accélère cette vaccination l'ouvrons je
suis tout à fait d'accord à ce qu'elle
dit pascal duo la niche qu'on nous
impose actuellement est trop restreinte
et on va tourner en rond et puis les
gens vont déborder mon choix ont triché
mon truc et c'est pas francs il faut des
règles franches les français ont droit
au patch 1 il ya des produits de qualité
donné donc d'honorer en deux doses c'est
ça le problème aussi pascal dureau et
puis à la défiance vis-à-vis
d'astrazeneca aussi qu'il faut prendre
en compte
wim cette défiance était pas justifiée
je veux dire que si vous regardez les
études de façon scientifique vous
apercevez que tous ces vaccins ont à peu
près le même effet indésirable et que
finalement la couverture vaccinale est à
peu près équivalente
donc je veux dire quand on est devant un
effet de rumeurs on est sur des saints
des sensations de de cheval sincèrement
dubouch des trucs de réseaux sociaux ça
n'a aucun sens ll ces vaccins sont
équivalents et il faut vacciner tout le
monde avec tous les vaccins qu'on peut
avoir et le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que nous faut plus de vaccins pour
vacciner plus rapidement 20 millions de
primo vacciner allah ni maître 30
millions à la mi juin
est ce que ce sont des objectifs tenable
selon vous patrick faure on nous même
pas en bateau c'est oui c'est tenable si
on accélère mais pour l'instant nous
dans nos cabinets on stagne donc pour
l'instant je veux dire que le coup de le
dire le coût qui va accélérer chose ça
viendra pas de chez nous parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire mieux je suis désolé on
veut faire mieux mais on ne peut pas
faire mieux pour l'instant d'abord parce
que on est limité en nombre de vaccins
johnson n'arrive pas on n'a pas accès
aux vaccins arn ce qui est dommage on
devrait pouvoir accès dans nos cabinets
c'est un rennes on nous parlait de
difficultés mais je vois qu'on vaccine
dans les stades de foot on vaccine dans
des bus donc nos cabinets finalement
c'est quand même mieux qu'à stade de
foot avec un buste ont un chien quoi on
a des friot il faut arrêter ce dès ce
délire
et puis cc c'est comme ça ces
interdictions si vous vacciner en moins
de soins 55 ans il arrive quelque chose
vous serez poursuivis non on est en état
d'urgence il faut que dépénaliser la
vaccination en disant que les gens qui
vaccinent son ne peuvent pas être
pénalement poursuivi durant cette
période d'état d'urgence parce qu'ils
remplissent mission de santé publique et
c'est une nécessité que l'état après
donne des indemnités si un accident
thérapeutique
on est bien d'accord mais menacé les
médecins de dire vous serez poursuivis
parce que
ou ne respectez pas les règles eh ben on
est on sera tous poursuivi je crois que
pascal après il a dit qu'il sera pour
six mois j'ai vacciner la semaine
dernière un facteur de 48 ans un peu en
surcharge pondérale un peu hypertendus
mais qui serre les mains de dizaines de
personnes à longueur de journée qui m'a
suppliée de vacciner j'ai fait mon job
de médecin je les vaccinés j'ai pris mes
risques
voilà mais imaginons qu'il arrive
quelque chose je termine ma carrière sur
un procès est ce que c'est normal non on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça il faut
adapter il faut que maintenant on aille
de l'avant que tous les médecins accès à
tous les vaccins et on y va et en font
c'est qu'ils ont on réhabilite les
vaccins discréditer moi ce que je disais
imaginons que le département du
haut-rhin sept cent mille habitants
on vaccine tout le département avec le
vaccin à sera imaginons qu'on le fasse
on aurait un décès le département du
haut-rhin 3000 morts faites le compte
3000 voire d'un côté un décès de l'autre
c'est vite fait les courses ou
d'annulation aussi dans certains centres
pour les pour la dose le vaccin
astrazeneca pascal dureau est ce que
finalement ouvrir la vaccination avec
les doses qui ne sont pas écoulés ce
sera une solution
oui je crois qu'il faut arrêter ce débat
qui est faux débat qui piquent loin
débat franco français
on est le seul pays au monde qui se pose
ces questions là tous les autres pays du
monde ont compris que la vaccination
était une chance exceptionnelle et ils
en profitent
est ce que vous rassurer que 90% de la
population mondiale nous envie de
pouvoir nous faire vacciner
donc on s'est un peu d'aidé des truc de
gamin c'est des gamines dit que de
commencer à regarder comme ça si une
mouche dans la soupe
la plupart du monde n'y a pas de sous
pas arrêté là on va s'intéresser à la
date du 30 juin parce qu'à ce moment là
le couvre-feu ça sera terminé
définitivement avec au préalable un
décalage progressif à partir du 19 mai à
21h et le 9 juin à 23h
d'abord est-ce que c'est une mesure le
coup
refus qui a produit des effets positifs
est-ce que son maintien de façon décalée
on voit là les dates prévues va
participer efficacement à lutter contre
l'épidémie on sait que c'est très
contraignant en ce moment pour les
français un confinement enfin un
couvre-feu à 19 heures patrick fat jeu
honnêtement je ne suis pas spécialiste
du couvre-feu
je pense que ça a eu un effet mais je
pense que quand on regardera les
chiffres c'est en effet sans doute plus
modeste que ce qu'on pense je crois
qu'il faut toujours rester très humble
par rapport à ces virus c'est lui qui
décide ce qui fait et nous nous essayons
de d'aménager un peu d'échapper au virus
sur la baie on voit bien que ce sont les
rencontres ce sont les liens il ya tout
au long de l'année il ya des des liens
l'actuellement on traversera mme adam et
malheureusement dans la ville où je suis
il ya beaucoup de familles qui sont
touchées parce que c'est lié au fait que
les gens se regroupent fond vous faites
là font la fête ensemble ils sont la
maison le couvre-feu est parfaitement
respectée mais voyez que le visible et
s'il est passé par les par les fenêtres
il est là quand même
donc il faut arrêter de penser que ces
mesures décrétées dans des mystères par
des théoriciens de l'épidémiologie sont
formidables elles ont eu des effets je
dis pas mais mais mais mais mais il faut
quand même être très humble parra sport
civil c'est lui qui nous dicte la règle
est ce qu un 0-100 le couvre-feu oui
enfin c'est qu'il faut demander aux gens
d'être responsable je ne crois pas que
de mettre des règles de cet ordre là qui
de toute façon ne sont pas respectées et
nous n'avons pas un policier derrière
chaque personne pour le faire je crois
ça discrédite l'action de l'état l'état
au moment de faire confiance à la
population et mais les appelés à être en
garde de continuer à protéger à penser à
son prochain
pire encore on met un masque et c'est
pas pour se protéger soi c'est pour
protéger son prochain quand je le
dressing pour protéger mon prochain
et c'est parce que aujourd'hui on veut
pas aux contaminés son voisin selon que
l'on doit faire attention
il faut sortir donner vie vitalisme n'a
pas de sens romaine capacité à vacciner
va sinon faisant attention à chacun rod
vous et c'est comme ça que nous pourrons
arriver à sortir satis en tout cas le 30
juin
on nous annonce un retour à une vie
normale
je sais que vous n'êtes pas devin mais
est-ce que c'est réaliste 1 le pass
annie terre aussi israël sera en vigueur
depuis le 9 juin
oui je crois que c'est parce sanitaire
c'est une bonne chose oui effectivement
si c'est peut-être la petite carotte
excusez-moi d'expression qui peut
inciter les gens à se vacciner d'avoir
un pass sanitaire aux états unis je
reprends de l'état l'exemple des états
unis
ils ont annoncé clairement que les gens
vaccinés pour s affranchir du port du
masque et des mesures barrières dans
l'intimité d'un milieu professionnel pas
en lieu dans les tous lieux publics mais
c'est quand même un début de reconnaître
que le vaccine à le vaccin protège quand
on est vaccinés on ne tombe pas malade
et on ne transmet pas la maladie je
crois qu'il faut revenir au principe
même de la médecine
le vaccin protège l'individu et la
société les gens vaccinés devront quand
même avoir un petit plus que les gens
réfractaires pour peut-être incité comme
les gens réfractaires en dix ans va
écouter vous ne pouvez pas compter quand
même sur la solidarité des autres si
vous ne participez pas à une vie normale
pascal dureau le 30 juin c'est réaliste
de toute façon je crois que la vie sera
jamais normal après cet épisode là parce
que je veux dire qu'on vient d'ouvrir
une porte et il y aura d'autres défilés
mais il y aura d'autres maladies donc
simplement il va falloir qu'on apprenne
un petit peu a changé on apprenne à ne
pas sortir
aller se promener quand on est malade ou
comportements ce qu'apprend on va te
laver les marais apprendre à se laver
les mains un peu plus souvent dans la
journée je dire ce qui était stupéfiant
cette année c'est qu'on n'a pas eu de
grippe
si vous revenez pas si bon témoin de
faerie je pense pas des immigrés mais
pourquoi parce que les gens étaient
mesures barrières unicorp arrière merci
à vous pascal dureau médecin généraliste
à vénissieux délégué national du
syndicat mg france merci également à
vous patrick pop
vous êtes un médecin généraliste à
mulhouse